oh
uh
i don't think
good morning everyone um
hopefully we all know how to work the
microphones
if you um
push the red button
and that will
leave it on
if you push the blue button
uh you you need to hold it down
and um then you can talk
also
just to
get
a couple of
informational items
based on venue availability
the next session is going to be moved up
to the week of the 14th of february
don't have a date yet don't have a time
or a place
but um
when
aaron and
the speaker were out looking for a place
they couldn't find it
couldn't find one for the week
that we had um
the
that was scheduled so
and we decided they decided that it
wasn't good in the middle of winter to
meet outside
so you're quite you're quite welcome
so um
what that means is that um
all of the bills that are going to
second committee
are now moved up a week
okay for and
i think they told me there were 102
that are currently out there
hopefully uh
a lot of them will
not pass muster so
because i i certainly don't want to be
faced with
bills in finance
no that's total second committees but as
you know we get about 75 of them so
okay so that's just for your um
for your planning purposes
um the other thing is um
written testimony where the person
doesn't come in
to speak
uh that is online
uh on the general court website under
the house
and
i will
ask
i will ask janet
to
please review that if there are things
in there that are important to us
then we will
need to
take care of that so anyhow that's
enough for me i
am since i am the
the sponsor
of 1677
i am going to turn this over to
representative emrick
and i will
move
as you might expect our first pink card
is representative umberger
so
uh good morning for the record i am
representative karen umberger
and i represent
conway eaton
chatham
hales location
and
carroll county
district 2.
so i'm here this morning to introduce
hp
i will start out by saying a i am not a
lawyer
so don't ask me any legal questions
that's why we have
the attorney general here to uh to
answer any of those
uh so that's that's number one
i think that everyone is aware from the
newspapers anyhow
that the ag's office is
conducting a broad
criminal investigation
into the allegations of sexual abuse
at the youth development center now
known as the sununu center
these allegations span multiple decades
and it has been publicly reported
that hundreds of individuals have come
forward
stating that they were
[Music]
victims of sexual abuse
while they were incarcerated
at ydc and the sununu center
this bill
is here
to provide an option
for the victims
that uh
instead of having however many trials
none of the victims
need to go through this process
however they can choose to go through
the process
of
instead of
going to trial
and if we have hundreds
of trials
this unfortunately
will no doubt go on for years and years
so the process that we have identified
here
is a way to
provide
compensation
for the
victims
without bogging down the court system
if they choose to go this way
it's
absolutely
their and their lawyers
choice
uh we have had
several people
that have worked on
putting this
bill together
and
we have had
many changes from the original until
what we see here
and
um
for those of you
we also
have an amendment
did janet distribute that
okay
and um so that will be um
that will will if people agree to it
then obviously that will become part of
the bill
in an effort
to
make sure
that
this
process
gets fully vetted all over the place
division 3 and division 1
will be holding a work session on
wednesday
to
go through i guess the term is with a
fine-tooth comb
what we hear today
and
what we think is the best thing for
the uh the victims
i will point out that um
as we
the reason the the reason we set up this
work session as division one and
division two or division three excuse me
is um
because division one handles the ag's
office
and division three
handles the sununu center
so it needed to be
a combination
of the two
divisions to try to come up with
a workable solution
at the end
so
that's all i have
unless um
there are
any questions that i can answer
question
she didn't hear you is your button down
my button down my mouth's not opening
okay
sad okay okay um i'm just gonna ask you
three questions today i'll hold the
others but um the first is
why um
did you have the date that this is they
can
people that were victims as of 1980 or
after 1980
um there it's my understanding there are
some victims prior to that so i was
curious why that date was chosen
uh if you don't mind i will let the
attorney general answer that question
and then the other two are financial
ones
okay um
why
the hundred million is
a large amount but my guess is that
that's um
that there would could be more
that would be needed
and so the question i'll combine the two
the question is why the hundred million
instead of higher and also my and from
looking at my interesting is we're
capping
the amount that could go to any one
claimant would be 1.5 million here
some of the cases that have come to
light
in the media accounts in any way are
quite egregious that might
actually get
larger settlements in other cases so i'm
curious as to why you chose those two
amounts why the 1.5 and why the 100
million okay
100 million was chosen
because if all of the cases
decide to go to court
we have
no you know no reasonable
assessment of of what that might be and
that's why the hundred million
okay
uh the 1.5
if i remember correctly
was because that was the
average
settlement
for
uh
victims
over time
thank you okay
other questions
seeing none thank you thank you
next witness is representative pat long
thank you mr chair
and i want to thank the honourable
members of the finance committee
i'll be submitting my written testimony
i'm representative pat long
representative representing hillsborough
district 10 in manchester
i speak in support of house bill 1677.
i believe that it's important to
recognize that abuse did take place and
for those victims to be able to see
compensation and matters clarified in
house bill 1677
i also believe that victims may be able
to proceed in attaining full or as close
to foreclosure to their abuses knowing
the state recognizes that those abuses
took place
i know this committee will review this
bill with due diligence and submit its
best recommendation to the general court
i have a few areas of the bill which i
would like to bring to your attention
on page one line two the word may i
believe it's important
to the victims that this body
acknowledges the abuses did occur
however i'm not familiar with legal
unintended consequences
i believe that our acknowledgement of
the abuses is greater in the recovery
stage for those victims than the
compensation
page one line 18 sexual abuse
i would ask for consideration of
physical abuse and unlawful confinement
i realized the time frame of honor after
january 1st 1980
and i'm unfamiliar with the potential of
added financial implications
on page 2 line 30 the notice
requirements of a newspaper
be posted in every
county in new hampshire
we know in new hampshire the issue with
young adults leaving a state and would
suggest consideration to a notice in the
national publication
page 3 line 22
claimant waiving rights prior to
proceeding with claims
and also page 5 line 5 and section 11
shared costs by claimant i ask that both
of those be reviewed
uh to
[Music]
benefit the claimant
in closing i thank the sponsor for
bringing house bill 1677 forward and i
would also like to publicly thank mr mrs
lenahan of salem
may god rest their souls i must be
having an allergy to my deodorant or
something here
uh whom in 1966 after spending eight
years at an orphanage
being told by my social worker that
there were no foster family that would
take
my brother and i and that i would be
going to ydc
agreed to take my brother and i in their
home
although they already had six or seven
children of their own
it's a true testament of new hampshire's
family
units caring
and i wish that i had thanked them in
their living years
thank you mr chair
i'll take any any questions
seeing none thank you for your testimony
thank you
next witness is john fernally
thank you representative emmerich
madam chair members of the committee uh
for the record john formella attorney
general
um i'm also joined today by assistant
attorney general jen ramsey who who can
assist in answering any questions as
i've been working with her on this
matter and we have both worked together
to help
draft the bill that you see before you
today
before i get to the core of my remarks i
just want to hit a couple of points
you know first and most importantly i
want to acknowledge the the difficult
emotional and complex topic that this
bill addresses and that we're
discussing
um i can't say that i can begin to
understand the experiences that that
these victims from ydc have gone through
that they've suffered and
and what it's taken for them to both
live with those experiences and come
forward
to tell their stories
i and my team we admire their courage
and
we admire their fortitude in coming
forward and
enabling us to look into what happened
at ydc over over so many years
we sincerely hope that this bill will
provide an opportunity for healing at
least for some of the victims because i
really do believe that this this should
be a time for healing
second i just want to remind the
committee that when it comes to this
matter in my answering questions
it's the unique nature of the attorney
general's role that i i sort of
fulfill a dual function in the state i'm
both the chief prosecutor who's
responsible for overseeing the
investigation prosecution
of these crimes on the criminal side of
our office
and i'm also the state's chief legal
officer who's responsible for defending
the state against any civil claims that
might arise from
the same events that we're prosecuting
for
i know that can be difficult especially
for the public to understand
but i just wanted to lay that out
because that may constrain me a bit in
what i can talk about and what questions
i can answer
but i will commit to you that i will
make every effort to answer all of your
questions and in the follow-up work
sessions that we have
we will do our best to get you all of
the information you need as you consider
this bill
representative umberger already
mentioned it but as many of you know the
the office has been conducting a broad
criminal investigation into
events at the youth development center
or ydc since 2019
to date that's resulted in the
indictment of 11 individuals
for acts of abuse committed against 20
victims
the reality is that we've had to this
date over 400 individuals come forward
and the investigation and prosecution of
crimes related to these allegations will
take many years
it's our commitment to to look into
the stories that that we hear from every
individual
and to do that right that's going to
take time
as we investigate these crimes we are
mindful of stats various statutes of
limitations and you know no allegations
will go
uninvestigated before the relevant
statute runs as long as that statute
limitations has not already run or
didn't already run before these events
came to our attention
while so many have come forward i think
the reality is we won't know the full
scope
of of the harm or or what occurred at
ydc for some time as we continue to
investigate
with all of this in mind
my team and i at the department of
justice
as we've as we've looked into these
events as we've thought about them
we've come to believe and we recommend
that
um the state
develop a claims resolution process that
would provide a trauma-informed
and victim-centered alternative to the
traditional litigation process for
victims who would choose that option
i think we all know that the traditional
litigation process can be incredibly
difficult
it's especially difficult for
victims of sexual abuse and even more
difficult for victims who were children
at the time that they suffered that
abuse
i'm going to i want to give you a little
overview of the bill and i'm happy to
answer questions at least an overview
from our perspective but i want to start
by confirming what this bill is not and
i think representative umberger already
hit that well
the bill is not intended to set up an
exclusive process by which victims must
go through to pursue compensation
it's intended to provide an option
so a more victim-friendly and
trauma-informed option
but even if this bill were to be enacted
any victim would have the option of
pursuing the traditional litigation
process and pursuing their their claims
in court
second
and this hits to
one of representative long's comments at
least as drafted the bill is not
intended to
cover any category of abuse that someone
may have suffered at ydc
it provides an alternative path for
victims of sexual abuse
for other types of harms the bill would
not prevent a victim from going through
the court process
and and i will be happy to answer
that question in more detail but i'll
just say initially that
the reason
our initial recommendation was to cover
sexual abuse is because
we we have seen throughout history
claims of physical abuse and excessive
force in prison settings
and and there's no question that type of
abuse is abhorrent and
and someone may come forward with a
claim of that abuse what we have not
confronted at least in the history of
our state is this type of scope
of sexual abuse in a prison setting and
especially a youth incarceration setting
and from my perspective it's
it's that
those extraordinary circumstances that
warrant
a unique and extraordinary um response
and in a different process or at least
an option for a different process
that said that's certainly a component
of this bill that we are happy to have
further discussions on and answer
questions on and and while that might be
our recommendation the decision will
ultimately be up to you but i wanted to
give you an initial sense of our
thinking on that topic
overall representative umberger already
hit this but but the bill provides an
initial appropriation of 100 million
dollars to to the ydc settlement fund
and the goal would be to fund
claims that would be paid out through
the process that the bill lays out
the hundred million dollars is not
intended i i don't think to be a cap
the bill specifically contemplates that
the attorney general may need to come
back to the legislature to request
additional funds to pay all claims in
full
but the hundred million dollars is
intended to be a set aside for now
and
until we have really
seen the full scope i think of what the
financial impact would be under this
process
the bill creates a one-year window in
which
victims would have the opportunity to
come forward and it really wouldn't be
until the end of that one year period
and until we've gone through
the
the verification and investigation and
and the claims negotiation and payout
process that we would we would know the
full financial impact of this bill so
that that's where the 100 million dollar
number i think from my perspective comes
the 1.5 million dollar cap and i'm happy
to talk about this in further detail as
well
that is a result of the research that
that we have done in our office
of past comparable claims or past
comparable cases verdicts and
settlements in other cases with
with similar facts
as i say that i do want to acknowledge
that
you know it's important to remember that
every victim has their own story and and
we really don't want to lose sight of
seeing each victim for for the
individual
circumstances of what they experienced
and
and what the impact has been on them
that said you know when we think about a
mass resolution of this type i think the
best the best information we have to at
least construct a broad process is to
look at comparable cases that have
happened in recent years so the 1.5
million dollar number
we think that number would allow us to
design a process that
would result in claims that are
consistent with the national average
that we've calculated in comparable
cases which is between which
comes out to about five hundred thousand
five hundred fifty thousand dollars per
claimant
obviously some claimants would be below
that number some would be above it but
that that's that's the overall average
and so that's what we used when we were
trying to calculate this 1.5 million
dollar
cap
the bill as as chairman umber
mentioned it would require a publication
process so notice would go out to
everyone
who may have a potential claim or we
would do our best to provide notice to
everyone
the bill covers claimants with
allegations from 1980 through the
present this gets to representative
rogers question
we picked this date for a couple reasons
one
just the basic idea that i think there
needs to be some date at which we we
have a cut off
i think there's room for discussion on
what what this date would be but 1980 is
the best rough date we could come up
with based on what i've seen on the
criminal side and where
what i
based on that information what i've seen
is kind of where these where these
events and allegations focused around
we're going to continue to get more
information through the civil process
and i'm sure we'll have get more
information as we now discuss this bill
publicly and have folks testify so i i
certainly think there's room for
discussion around that date but that's
that's how we came up with the date of
1980 i'm best informed by what i've seen
on the criminal investigation which i'm
somewhat constrained to what i can talk
about but
1980s is really where where that date
came from but as we get more information
on the civil side i think we probably
warrants further discussion
another issue that i'm sure will warrant
discussions that the bill permits
any claim to be paid out in annual
installments of up to 10 years
important piece there is that that that
is that does not mean that
a claim has to be paid out over 10 years
it's it's an option
so there may be instances in which
someone would prefer that there may also
be instances in which that's part of the
negotiation between
the fund administrator and the claimant
it may also be a factor for an
arbitrator as as they're looking at the
claim in front of them and they're
deciding
how to structure an award and how to pay
it out so that
that's
that's what the thinking is regarding
the installments that's not meant to be
a requirement that all claims are paid
out in installments of 10 years
uh we can go into this in more detail if
there are questions maybe in the work
session but the bill sets out
a procedure for making and filing and
reviewing and investigating and paying
out claims
um
that's our best attempt to con i think
lay out broad parameters for a process
that we think would allow for a
trauma-informed and victim-centered
process but we are certainly open to
to more feedback on that and and
obviously the ultimate decision is going
to rest with with you is the elective
elected representatives but
this reflects our best recommendations
and we are here at your service to
continue to continue discussing those
points
that's a that's a high-level overview of
the bill i'm sure there are points i've
missed but i will take any questions you
have
before i close i just want to make
a couple of additional points
the first is that
i think the most important part of the
reasons behind this bill is that we we
believe designing and implementing this
type of a claims resolution resolution
process that provides an option for
victims
is just simply the right thing to do
and it's what new hampshire does we i
think we we do the right thing we make
our best attempt to do the right thing
it's the right thing for victims
who should have an alternative option
that provides for faster and gentler
resolution than the traditional
litigation process
and i firmly believe it's the right
thing for the state
not only because it constitutes a
recognition of the harm that these
victims have suffered
but it directs the state's resources
towards healing and compensation
rather than costly litigation and it
also does provide a level of certainty
to the state regarding the financial
risk or at least it could if victims
elect this option
all that said we as i've mentioned
before we we do not yet know the full
extent of the financial potential
financial impact of the state
second i think i've already hit this but
i want to make this point
we put a lot of work into this proposal
we put a lot of thought into this
proposal i know we've already worked
with legislators of both parties
but we recognize that the public process
and the legislative process now is just
beginning
so we're eager to engage with
plaintiff's council we're either too
eager to engage with advocacy groups
we're eager to make ourselves available
to you to answer questions and assist
we're eager to have conversations with
with victims themselves if they so chose
to get feedback on this bill
and to
develop the best possible product that
we can while balancing at least from the
perspective of my office our obligations
to
to defend and represent the state
and the last thing i will i'll just
commit to is that if this bill is
enacted and
the attorney general
is authorized to design this type of
process
we will do everything possible to design
a process that is as victim-friendly and
trauma-informed
as possible
that's what this is about
so
just to close i want to thank you for
your time and thank you for for
considering this
and i also just want to say that
you know just the fact that legislators
were willing to bring this forward makes
me very proud
it makes me proud of the state
it makes me proud that
we are willing to acknowledge some of
the terrible events that have happened
that we're willing to have these
conversations that we're willing to make
an effort to atone
and that we're willing to make an effort
to bring this much needed relief
to our fellow citizens
so with that i'm happy to answer
questions and we will be available at
every work session we will be available
anytime you you need to speak with us as
we work on this bill
thank you
representative
red okay
well anyways thank you mr chair and
thank you for your effort towards this
um unimaginable
circumstance that's been created
i heard the number of 20 that's being i
guess litigated now up to 400 is that is
that a minimum
maximum and
along with that why i'm thinking about
that is i have no earthly idea how you
can place
a value
to the harm done
in
this horrible
acts and
um
what
do you have a sense of minimum maximum
or
what
briefly if this is appropriate now uh
what's the process to
obtain a value
for harm done if if it is that a fair
question
yeah very fair question i i think
there's a couple questions in there yes
i'll try to hit them all and if i don't
feel free to follow up
yes so i think your first question was
to the the number of cases
and i want to make sure i clarify that
on the criminal side we have so far
indicted 11 individuals for acts against
20 victims that's on the criminal side
um i think we all need to keep in mind
that there's a much higher burden as we
know on the criminal side we are only
going to bring bring a charge if we
think we can prove a case beyond a
reasonable doubt and these these are
very difficult cases because
uh for a number of reasons but
these are always difficult cases in
general but these are many of these
cases are very old many years ago
we don't have the best records
memories fade
victims of abuse and i'm not an expert
on this so i don't want to pretend to be
but i i understand that that victims of
abuse as years go by
don't always have the clearest memory of
what happened so so as we try to put
these cases together it's very difficult
to
to put together a criminal case that we
can prove beyond a reasonable doubt so
while we have indicted 11 individuals
for acts against 20 victims
and we're certainly not done
investigating you know the
the number 20 on the criminal side i
think we should think about is as a
different category
on the civil side we we've had over four
and this has been publicly reported at
this point i mean we've had over 450
individuals come forward and they have
spoken with our
our team on the criminal side and
they've also we've also gotten their
names on on the civil side
so
that's the number as of now
i don't know what the maximum number is
i i i couldn't tell you because of that
we've had thousands of of you
young people at ydc over the years so i
don't know what the maximum is but but
to date we've had
between 4 and 450 who we know of that
have come forward but we continue to
investigate
and we will continue to do so for some
time
as to the value how we would design a
value i spoke about the the overall
number of 1.5 million
the
the way we would design the process and
we would seek input from
from victims attorneys we seek input
from advocacy groups but we would
probably end up
with
some type of matrix
that was based on amounts that have been
paid out for certain types of harm in
the past
to your to the question you asked
representative or the comment you made
is to you don't know how you could value
this type of harm i mean i agree you
know
it
there's no amount of money
i think that that really truly
compensates for this type of harm
that that that's just a fact i can't
like i said i can't imagine the horrors
that some have experienced and
and so there's no
i think there's no dollar amount that
would ever fully compensate someone
the
the best we can do i think is to
look at what's been done in the past try
to pull from best practices try to
try to design something that's fair
and that provides
enough
so that a victim
feels that they
they've received some measure of justice
enough so that it makes a difference in
their lives and helps
help helps aid them in some healing and
and i think we can i think there's also
value in the fact that we would be
acknowledging that this happened
and we would be listening and and um
helping a victim to feel heard
so but there's no
dollar amount that i i think we could
ever land on no matter how high
that we could truly say it's enough
or it's sufficient
yeah i think
yes represent land
walls thank you mr chairman
um so as i recall and i don't have the
data but i'm doing this from memory many
of the settlements in the catholic
church cases were in excess of a million
for those victims
and those were not violent rapes
according to the news reports that i
read in the paper and that's all i have
for this is many of the
rapes at the youth detention center were
quite violent with
the
guards holding people down and violent
rape sometimes it sounds like with
multiple perpetrators involved
that is
a much more onerous crime in some i mean
rapist or nurse no matter what but it
would seem to me and the law i think
recognizes that violent rapes are even
more onerous than non-violent rapes in
the same way
and and i'm getting into very dangerous
territory
at any rate what i'm trying to suggest
is is if
people in those cases were getting a
million why is 1.5 million adequate when
potentially the the rapes were so much
more onerous at the sununu center and
i'm wondering if we're comparing apples
to oranges here and if we shouldn't be
raising that cap of 1.5 million for
people who are victimized in such a
violent manner
and i will just say for the record
because i know this is public i know all
rapes are violent but there are
levels of violence and that's what i'm
talking about here
thank you representative i appreciate
the question
so
based on the research we've done and
one thing i should mention we're we're
open to if others have more information
or or i think folks who are here to
testify today have additional
information to provide i mean we we want
to see it too but
based on the research we've done i'm not
sure that at least the
the church cases in this state were over
a million dollars per claimant and we
will we will provide this to you
our research and i think we have copies
we have copies that we can pass out
but but that's the first point but but
to the extent we're wrong on that or or
there's information we may not have we
we certainly are open to it um
but this research doesn't just look at
church cases i mean it looks at i think
of a wide variety of
uh or at least a
a fair number of past cases that that
range from
instances which
may include
uh more violent acts or
or instances which may be less violent i
think to your point it's just very hard
to put a definition on that because any
you know how do you define violent in
the context of
someone who's been victimized
or a victim of sexual abuse because i
think
any victim would feel that that's quite
violent which i which i know you
acknowledge
the
part of this process is designed to
you know start with the victim coming
forward and telling us what happened to
them
we have we have some details on that so
far
on the criminal side but
but there's still a lot of information
we we don't have or that we may not have
the full story so
um the 1.5 million dollar cap is based
on all types of cases that we've looked
at
and and that's why we think that
that is
that's a number that that makes sense
to the extent that we
we get additional information or
additional information is provided to us
or provided to you
you know i think it's i think it's worth
a discussion but
but i i think we just want to make sure
i think to your point we don't want to
be comparing apples to oranges you know
we want to be comparing like cases
i think we're doing that but to the
extent that we're not
we should continue to have conversation
about that but we will provide you our
our verdict research and
and i think that will show at least why
we've come to the number we came to as a
recommendation
follow-up yes were you also looking at
the massachusetts settlements because i
think they are also relevant here are
you just looking at the new hampshire
settlements no we've looked at
settlements from all states so um i mean
i think i think we've focused on the
the church settlements in new hampshire
but but we've looked at other types of
settlements from from various states but
but we're really
the unfortunate reality is that
sexual abuse can happen in
many different settings we're we were
trying to focus on settings you know
similar to the youth development center
where
where individuals or youth may be
incarcerated or may
may be in a situation where there's
someone in a position of authority who
would commit these acts
yeah representative rogers
thank you um
thank you for answering my other
questions as well and
um for being willing um i'm very
supportive of the concept i just have a
lot of questions about dates
and numbers so i'm glad that you're
willing to um
talk to us about the date the 1980 date
and the amount but the other um
time frame that i'm concerned about and
i'll go ask you a lot more questions in
the work session but you have roughly a
year i think it's exactly a year for the
claimants to come forward
i know that a lot of them have come
forward already but is
it struck me that just a year is a short
time so is that something also that um
we could look at is is maybe
expanding that to two years i mean i'm
not sure what the time is as with all of
this we're all kind of guessing it
amounts to dates but i wondered why you
picked just one year
and if that's something that you think
we can look at
yep i absolutely think it's something we
can look at i think we we were trying to
you know
pinpoint a time period that would
provide enough time but also
you know
have a cut-off date at some point at
least for for this process only so that
we can get to a point where we have a
better sense of of the scope of what
happened
so i but i think from our perspective a
year especially given that that year
will not even start until september 1 of
this year and and there's been a lot of
discussion about this we'll continue to
have a lot of discussion about this
between now and september 1.
we felt a year was probably enough time
but
that that is
that is i think definitely a topic to
discuss further because that could
certainly be expanded and from my
perspective at least for you know from
from the perspective giving legal advice
to you as the state's elected
representatives i wouldn't see a concern
with expanding that at all
follow-up yes the other only other
question i'll probably today just not
find us down
in the um bill it also has that the
claimants would
if they accept a settlement go through
the process they would waive their
rights to
go to any other forum
and against the state
or its employees and my concern is the
employees
if the employees that perpetrated these
crimes on folks
as we've all said some of them
are are
just or meant most of them are egregious
but i'm wondering if there's that's fair
to cut the victims off from pursuing
actions against the actual perpetrators
of the crime be they employees of the
state
but go after them individually and
personally instead of um
or in addition to this process and what
you're thinking was there i mean it's
kind of like we're protecting these
people that were clearly criminal in
their actions
yeah thank you for the question
representative
the complaints that have been filed um
to the extent they're filed against
employees of the state you know they're
not just filed against employees who who
committed the acts
filed against the commissioner file
against others
for for negligence in in oversight and
and the um the running of the facility
and the supervision of the facility so
that's really what that
this
this comes from the concept i think the
reality that while these complaints name
even the individual employees who
committed the acts
the real defendant that
that these complaints are aimed at is
the state because it's the state that
has the ability to pay out compensation
i i
i can't speak here off the top of my
head to say the criminal defendants or
the other individuals who are accused of
committing these acts but my sense is
most of them are would not have the
financial means anyway to to pay
anything close to what would be adequate
compensation especially to multiple
victims so
um
this this would not in any way prevent
the state from pursuing criminal charges
against those individuals or prevent the
victims from participating in in those
criminal proceedings in order to allow
enable them to move forward
okay
other questions yes please
thank you mr chair
my question um if this bill passes um
how will it be administered i know you
you designated an administrator will it
become um a group within your office who
will oversee this and so that we know
that this will be handled with the
utmost dignity and respect for those
victims that i cannot believe quite
frankly
40 years this has gone on and and
we're here this morning and it's just
very disheartening to hear this
information
um so could you elaborate on that for me
please sure
yeah
i think the first point on that is the
bill is i think designed to to put some
parameters in place but that would allow
some flexibility so that we could design
the process the right way but but i
think how it would end up playing out or
this is close to how it would play out
is
as drafted the bill would authorize me
as attorney general to designate someone
to be the administrator
the bill allows for
administrative costs to come out of the
fund
but we would use both current personnel
and perhaps
contracted personnel or others that we
hire on a temporary basis to
to help administer this so to help
take in the claims review them
get them investigated interview the
claimants uh do that in as
trauma-friendly and victim-centered way
as possible
uh but but i think to your question yes
it would it would be supervised
ultimately by the attorney general and
attorney general's office so that we
could ensure that it was handled the
right way
and then the arbitrator piece would be
in there so that there is a neutral
party if the administrator and the
claimant you know don't come to an
agreement on a number within the
guidelines it would be submitted to a
neutral arbitrator and both sides would
accept what that arbitrator determined
other questions
okay thank you
thank you for your testimony and we we
will stay the whole time so feel free to
call us back up if you need us okay
i have a feeling we'll see you next
wednesday yes next wednesday and
whatever else you schedule something for
okay next witness is david
this
cesano
i butchered that pretty well tonight
i'm very used to it representative
uh it used to be vicinanzo
in naples
but we've anglicized it to vissa nanzo
okay but it's still hard i i acknowledge
that i i spell it 15 times a day on the
phone
although i'm not i'm not a total
stranger to this body
um i've been in the state a long time i
used to run the u.s attorney's office
for many years
in fact justice lynn was a mentor of
mine
and a predecessor
um but this body actually is a former
client of mine the house of
representatives
i represented the house
and the last redistricting
and in fact this is kind of old home day
for me because i remember the last time
i think i was in front of justice lynn
uh looking down at me with that stern
uh
visage
that he has on the bench
i'm exaggerating of course
but uh in that case we uh we got a
unanimous decision from the state
supreme court for the first time in two
decades
we had put together a house plan of
redistricting that the court found was
constitutional and abided by perfectly
with the one person one vote principle
so i'm very proud of that and and uh i
want to note though that you are my
former clients
so
well now i have different clients
and
i want to really express my gratitude to
to this body and also to john farmela
we represent we meaning ross reilly and
myself
about 450 child victims in this case
as of yesterday as of last night we've
filed 449
lawsuits in merrimack county superior
court and
we regret having to tie up the the
superior court and tie up the office of
attorney general
but our folks have been denied justice
for decades
and justice is long overdue for them
i am so glad we are very grateful
that the attorney general and
this body
are beginning to address
this huge
grievous
wound on the integrity and the
reputation of our great state
it's sort of unbelievable i've begun to
really research some of the history
of how it could have happened
how
it went on for years and never really
was examined
there were rumors
but
i i think sometimes when you have kids
who's
for whom all the adults in their lives
have failed them
and that are put into a place no parents
no teachers no
nobody
no political constituency no real
constituency at all to look out for
their rights
it's very easy to forget them and that's
what happened here they were forgotten
and they were
abused terribly
and we have we'll get into this in a
moment but
we have kids who
report being
raped anally
up to 150 times over two two year period
while they're incarcerated
it's unbelievable became the the sexual
playthings of some of these
counselors who work there
uh taken from society cut off
no parents know anybody and
this legislature passed bills years ago
saying what should happen
and that
these are kids who who's all the adults
have failed them but now it's our job to
help launch them successfully into
adulthood and instead we take these
sheep
and bring them
into the wolf pen
and that's what happened here
i have another client who a a young
woman a woman who
14 years old but put in there
impregnated by one of these counselors
quote unquote
and then two other counselors take her
out for a forced abortion i mean you
can't make this stuff up
it's so unbelievable
i apologize for my emotion but
i have a lot of kids myself
including adopted kids
i have an adopted child from mexico
who was in an orphanage
and that orphanage
did a heck of a lot better job than what
we did with ydc
and it's a shame on us
it's a shame and i'm so grateful for
that orphanage in mexico
i apologize
so
but i'm very grateful to hear john say
that it's time for the state to do the
right thing
and it absolutely is
this should not be cannot be anything
like what the catholic church did when
the scandals started to emerge
you know you had the cardinal law
approach which is oh
you know we don't really want to hear
about this when we're doing so many
great things today that we can't afford
to take care of all these these
things in the past we can't afford it oh
well we saw what happened with cardinal
law how well that worked out for him
but there was a much more progressive
and much more liberal minded open-minded
approach that was taken
by others
cardinal o'malley was one of them and he
said look at we have no credibility
we have we have no right to do anything
until we take care of these past debts
until we take care of the children who
are harmed in our care by our own people
who's going to listen to you
if you don't do that
and he was right and and to a large
extent
there was a
fair amount of justice that was done to
the church's credit it's not always but
some a lot of times
um
we oppose the bill
not in concept but the way it's written
we do like the idea of a victim-friendly
trauma-informed mediation or arbitration
process
that's great that would be great but the
way it's written right now
i you know i've been doing this for
years decades working with victims of
trauma i still do and i i obviously and
and i've learned so much one of my
former partners is gordon mcdonald
gordon and i 20 years ago
working to get together developed a
trauma-informed victim-friendly process
for settlement of child sexual abuse
cases
and it's it's it's used very
successfully even then but it's gotten
better over time and it's used all over
new england and other parts of the
country very successfully
and we have you know we have a lot of
our victims who end at the end of the
process say
i feel
somewhat reconciled with the institution
that harm me
i feel like i've been validated i feel
like i've been heard and i i am
this has been really important in my
healing
and i i
anyway so this is a well trodden path we
don't have to reinvent the wheel here
what has to happen here already exists
and i wish that john and i had an
opportunity to talk we are going to talk
next week we i just we haven't we've
only met this morning for the first time
and and i
you know i'm very impressed with what i
heard him say and i'm confident that
that we're going to make some real
progress in turning this bill into
something that the victims will use
because ultimately the product is all
you know proof's in the pudding if the
if the customers don't use the product
then the product doesn't work right so
we've got to get it to the point where
these folks who've been terribly
traumatized
who
didn't try you know learned at an early
age not to trust people and do not trust
the state i hate to say it but they
don't
um they've got to get to the point where
they're actually going to trust the
state enough
that they'll participate and that
they'll feel that they're going to get a
fair shake and that is one of the things
that i would you know i'm just saying i
i'm not going to get into all the things
that we disagree with on the current
bill
because i want to focus on the positives
and i want to focus on what we're going
to do next week when we're working on it
and so forth but the idea that somehow
the victims have to
abandon all their other rights and or as
a price of admission to this process
it's a non-starter they're not going to
do that they don't have that level of
trust and we don't make them do that in
any other i represent other institutions
very sophisticated ones
and we don't make people do that we
don't you know it's it you always have
the right to pursue what your your
rights in court we don't make people we
don't coerce them into giving them up as
a price of admission so that's kind of a
bit of a faux pas i think i don't i
don't think that's going to work and it
shouldn't work because
i i think it's malpractice frankly for
me to recommend that to our clients
because these are very strong liability
cases
these are not the usual cases this is a
situation it's not a negligent
supervision case or a negligent hiring
case and i i know there are several
lawyers on the on the panel may
understand this
talking a little inside baseball here
but
the state had a fiduciary duty to these
kids they took them into custody and cut
them off from the rest of the world
and undertook to take total control of
them and care for them
that's different that when that happens
it's sort of like you know when a lawyer
gets a settlement and turns out his
secretary steals the money the lawyer
can't go to the client and say oh sorry
i didn't know my secretary was a
criminal i don't owe you any money no no
no you owe the money you owe the money
there's no free
bite there's no
there's no trial run if you breach your
fiduciary duty you oh you're liable
the other thing is there's no statute of
limitations on sexual assault anymore it
was abolished by this legislature last
year
and it's
especially with respect to the state
there's no
not even a bill of rights argument
there's no article 1
or part 1 article 23 argument there is
no statute of limitations and this does
go back to the point about 1980 i really
feel that that's an arbitrary cutoff the
church paid
altar boys that were abused back to the
1940s
just because you're a little bit elderly
why shouldn't you have some rights why
do you why pick 1980. i just
i know we'll talk about that and i think
we'll get to the right point on that but
i don't think you should discriminate
against people just because they're
older
you know and if they were abused they
were abused
so that's just one of the new various
things the the other thing is the
concept of a fund
funds i i i'm in the business i'm a
lawyer going on 40 years and i i you
know i i know when they talk about fund
it's usually the institution trying to
save money and
and it's particularly pernicious idea in
this case where you create a limited pie
and i know that may not be the intention
and probably isn't what gonna be what
eventually resolves here but you create
a pie and then you make the victims
fight for their limited peace
that's a horrible image here especially
with these victims so you know part of
what the state has learned and what
we've learned from our clients
is that there were a lot of times these
kids were made to fight
by the guards by the counselors they
used to fight over food you know
actually fist fights actually have them
fight for the entertainment of the
guards it's like a it's like a cage
match you know with these 15 year olds
fighting each other and the idea that
we're going to create a pot
or a pie that's limited and all the all
these traumatized people have to fight
each other for their little slice
no that is not a good very bad image
very bad image and again something that
is
somewhat repellent to to our clients and
they're probably not something that's
going to work
i'm mindful of my time and i don't want
to go on too long that we'll have
opportunity to speak uh next week and
i'm really looking forward to working
with john and and jen
uh
i had a great conversation with chairman
umberger yesterday and she i don't think
she's here anymore but i have to thank
her
oh i'm sorry okay thank you again uh
chair chairperson umberger
but she asked me or invited me to
edit the bill
in the next few days before the working
session which i'm very eager to do
and to come to the working group and
work with us so that the victims who we
represent and ultimately who are the
beneficiaries and the people that will
use this process are adequately
represented and that we actually get to
hear the victims perspective
um i'm also going to probably write a
letter
with that kind of explaining our
rationale
and um also probably presenting
what i alluded to earlier the process
that gordon mcdonald and i developed 20
years ago and is now kind of mainstream
i really feel like we don't have to
reinvent this wheel
um
i do one final thing i think is and it's
something that is it's already been
adequately addressed i think to some
degree but the idea of taking
an average national average of
settlements and sort of making that the
cap
i don't think that makes sense i mean i
mentioned i alluded to some of the
injured folks here and you know there
are cases that
would uh settle for much less than 1.5
you know there's there's a vast there's
quite a range of of what happened 50
times
as a 15 16 year old i don't know how you
put a price on that but i did i did just
see this uh the grid that was uh put
together
and i just scanning it but and i noticed
there's a lot that's missing here i mean
it doesn't address the the larry nassar
case the more recent stuff you know
nassar was the
usa olympics uh doctor the average
settlement there was the 1.5 million
that's the average and somewhere much
higher and that sort of abuse the abuse
there terrible abuse but you know that's
a doctor who's exceeding what a doctor
is supposed to do with the patient it's
not quite the same not the same as 150
anal rates i can guarantee you that
so so we should i would i would i'll
definitely be conveying that to to john
and to jen and to others
the church settlements more recently we
allude to some of the diocese
settlements but those are 20 years ago
and to a large extent before society
really realized how much harm is done by
this type of abuse
uh the church that settlements in l.a
more recently are in the 1.3 1.5 million
average
and again we don't know it all depends
on the facts
um brooklyn recently there's the four
kids church settlement
um the average there was seven million
now that's brooklyn
when i practiced in new york years ago
we used to call it the international
house of plaintiffs
but so maybe that maybe the values are
higher there but still
you know seven isn't 1.5 but it maybe
something in between is is something
that would be an appropriate one
uh and also the diocese settlements with
chuck douglas and um
peter hutchins i know because my firm
was involved gordon was very involved i
had a front row seat
through not just 20 years ago but
until gordon took the bench or or became
a g i'm sorry but those those
settlements have risen dramatically over
the years they were uh at the time
society that not had a had much
experience with sexual abuse and i think
those were very much undervalued they
also don't include mark abramson
settlements which were significantly
higher or any of the settlements since
there had been a lot of settlements
since they just haven't surfaced in the
public eye but the values now are much
higher
um so
i i really am very grateful for the
opportunity to speak today i'm i'm sorry
if i'm taking too much time i'm grateful
for your
you're uh allowing me to speak uh a
little bit more i have plenty more to
say and i'll save it for
my writings and for next week
i just want to leave you with this
thought and and i am reiterating it but
it's so important
the our clients these victims were kids
they had been failed by all the adults
and then they're placed in custody and
abused physically sexually in other ways
they learned early on not to trust
anybody and they have a one of their
problems is they go to therapy and the
therapists will say
you have a big problem with trust you
don't trust anybody that's why you're
you're a walking porcupine you know
you're scared of everything you're you
have ptsd a lot of them have ptsd
they don't trust people and they
especially they sort of think of the
state as one big entity they don't make
a distinction between the ag and hhs or
ydc it's all the same
so in order to actually get them to use
this process
we've got to try to get into their shoes
a little bit and see the world a little
bit the way they see it
and so in order to make this bill
attractive and i do think it's an
important thing to do to have an
alternative i think all of these cases
ought to be mediated or arbitrated in
some way nobody wants to clog up the
courts forever and nobody knows what a
jury will do with these i mean you know
we are waking up to the how much harm
sexual abuse in my on children it does
nobody wants that so i we want this to
work too but we have to remember who
your customer is here and
that's the victims so we've got to make
it appealing to them
and there is already a time-tested and
well-developed path that we can go down
and i want i look forward to the
opportunity to share my experience with
john and with jen and others and and the
committee and the legislature generally
so thank you very much and
i'm very grateful for the opportunity to
be here happy to take any questions if
you have some
knowing that we're going to have a full
work session next week
if you have any any questions you'd like
to ask or
i would prefer you wait until the work
session so we have a chance to review
your remarks i'm assuming we'll get some
kind of markup yes on the bill itself
uh so does anybody have any questions
that
would be
i'm sorry
oh sure yeah it's v like vector i
c i
n a n z o this in nonzone it's actually
pretty fanatic
it just if you angle size it
uh but it is intimidating to look at
and imagine that i've got 10 sons they
all have the same name
and the thing is we're only a little bit
italian
mostly irish
any other
questions thank you mr vincenzo okay
thank you
okay representative skip rollins
oh somebody stuck it out in front of me
here
16 okay we have len
scoley
good morning mr chairman and members of
the committee my name is lynn chalette
and i'm the executive director of the
new hampshire coalition against domestic
and sexual violence
it's a tall order to speak after the
attorney general and david vissenanzo
and many good points have been made this
morning so i can be very brief
i appreciate the forward momentum to
recognize the lifelong impact of severe
abuse that children received at the
hands of the state-run facilities were
talking about today
and we are happy to hear that the
attorney general is willing to continue
conversations about this piece of
the state has failed these children in
horrible horrible ways and it's our
obligation to make it right
representative walls i think you asked
some interesting questions about
different kinds of rape and i think one
of the things that's important for us to
focus on here is that children who are
raped in institutions face added layers
of consequences
in addition to the physical and
psychological abuse they've experienced
they have experienced an unspeakable
violation of trust by an institution an
institution that had a single mission
which was to raise them in a safe
environment
so the coalition is supportive of
victims being compensated for the
injuries they've experienced and the
care that they have sought
we know that survivors of childhood
sexual abuse have major financial
implications throughout their life
needing medical care mental health care
and they often often experience losses
in the educational setting and the
inability to keep jobs
a number of questions came up today
about the appropriate time frame of here
the tragedy is that with the passage of
time many of these consequences become
worse and survivors actually need more
care
that being said we believe there's more
work to be done for this bill to create
a process that is inclusive of fair to
and empowers victims
victims need a trauma-informed response
to help them heal and the financial
component is part of it but you also
heard the attorney general and mr
vicinanzo speak to the fact that
engaging victims in a meaningful way is
important
so we're optimistic about the work
session next week as well i would say
briefly that our concerns about the bill
fall into three buckets or three
categories
first and most importantly it's critical
for victims to have options in the
process that will make them whole
we don't believe that victims who engage
in this process should be denied the
ability to go to court if they get to
the end of this process and it doesn't
help them or they don't get any
compensation we believe they should be
able to retain that option
we have great concerns about the
financial cap we do believe that puts
victims in competition with one another
and that is not a trauma
response to what they experienced
and as representative long referenced
earlier we think the notice provisions
are impractical
and far too short so there are some
practical things like that we hope the
committee will work on
the second bucket is some process
concerns
the investigator and the administrator
are very linked in this process and we
believe those should be independent
entities we also have concerns about the
10-year payout period
finally our third bucket is about the
scope of this bill and several of these
issues have been raised today
it is narrow in terms of the
institutions that are covered we believe
it should look at all the state
institutions that have been involved in
perpetrating and covering up this abuse
it is narrow in terms of the crimes that
are covered for a victim who is beaten
one day and the next day has something
inserted into their body as a form of
sexual assault those traumas are
overlapping i don't think there's a
distinction for survivors who experience
these patterns of abuse over years
we also have concerns about the scope of
the dates and as i mentioned when we
look at survivors who experienced abuse
even earlier than this 1980 date what
that means is that they have lived with
their injuries even longer
so we're pleased that the attorney
general has committed to make this
process more trauma-informed and more
victim-centered and we look forward to
coming to the table next week and
throughout the session to try to make
this a process that will truly help
victims heal thank you i'm happy to take
any questions
do we have any questions
yes
i thank you for your testimony and
taking my question
you mentioned other state agencies could
you expand on that
yeah i i could and i also think that
attorney vicenzo is probably the best
one to come for to speak to that but we
know that over 400 victims have come
forward and have identified many other
institutions in addition to ydc and i'd
be happy to put a list together and
provide it with the commit to the
committee
thank you for your question
thank you for your time thank you very
much
our next witness is
laurie
ortolano
we do have written testimony from this
witness so i'm assuming she's
oh
good morning my name is lori ordolano
i'm the vice president of new hampshire
right to know
and we are opposed to one section of
this bill 1677
that we're looking for an amendment on
and that would be for the non-disclosure
of the settlement agreements
the right to know law 91a colon 4 says
that every agreement to settle a lawsuit
against a governmental unit threatened
lawsuit or other claim
entered into by any political
subdivision or its insurer shall be kept
on file at a clerk's office and made
available for public inspection for a
period of no less than 10 years
from the date of the settlement
it's unclear why with these settlements
redactions can't be performed on records
to protect the names of the individuals
involved
in nashua school district settlements
involving special education or an abuse
issue in a school
are available for inspection but
redactions are done and they also use
the family educational right protection
act ferpa regulations to protect the
privacy rights of
the student
the distribution of governmental funds
to settle these lawsuits should not be
withheld from the public and in
listening today it looks like this is
certainly an evolving bill
in the scope of it and the amount of it
and the number of victims
we're looking at estimates now and you
folks are going to be at the table
debating this and working on this for
some period of time
so please do not exempt these records
from the existing statute under the
right to know law thank you
any questions
thank you for your testimony
and that concludes the
hearing on
uh
i mean i have a lot of questions
the address i don't like
all right we will now open the hearing
on hb
uh 1300.
and i would ask
representative skip rollins to
come to the table and he will
introduce the bill
whoa
thank you madam speaker for the record
my name is representative skip rollins
representing sullivan
district six which is newport unity
today i'm here to introduce the house
bill 1300 fn a
um last
yesterday afternoon i received an
amendment for this i've emailed that to
uh
ols
they started working on it as of this
morning just before nine the amendment
isn't ready yet but i do have a rough
draft right here of what i sent in if
the committee would like to see this now
i did ask and the
house committee services will be
emailing you that amendment as soon as
that
amendment is ready
uh representative rollins we will be
scheduling a division two
work session on this
and so uh you are
we are more than willing to accept the
final amendment or the amendment at that
time at that time okay and i'd we'd
rather i think
see what ols actually puts put together
so we'll just ask that um
you be prepared to uh
come and talk to us when that session is
scheduled all right thank you very much
i'd like to defer all questions right
now to the next speaker who is the
expert on this and thank you for your
time
are you mark yes
i am
oh well i
you have been so designated yes i have
um
so thank you so much for hearing from us
today my name is mark pitkin and i
represent the economic corporation of
newport
so i'm going to be as brief as i can
because we are in a situation where we
are behind or between a rock and a hard
place so to give you some perspective as
to why this bill is coming forward
back in 2006 we had an ash landfill that
was owned and operated by 27 districts
most in new hampshire some in vermont
and then newport not wanting to be
considered the trash town and having all
of this ash basically come forth through
town through the entire new england
states
we worked with the 27 communities and
des such that we would be the only
non-profit entity a landfill to put it
in conservation easement and for the
benefit of the citizens of newport
so when that originally came into
existence through those three folks
working together
because we are not a municipality that
has the ability to tax we are not one of
the large
uh disposal corporations that have huge
balance sheets and we are basically an
economic development corporation with a
mission that is to improve sort of the
betterment of businesses and citizenry
in newport
um we decided we would move forth and
then the des at that point in time
required us to have a trust fund so we
couldn't look to any other type of
financial assurance with regards to the
post-closure expenses over time so a
trust fund was put together the monies
were put in by the 27 districts and we
were successful in getting a permit
modification from the state again as
being the only non-profit to take on
this particular and potential project
so everything was going well and we
provide on a regular basis something
called financial assurance so you always
have to show that you have enough money
in whatever mechanism you have to cover
that landfill for a certain period of
time so when this agreement was
originally put together it was put
together with the expectation that it
was a 30-year period so all of the
monies that were put in place by those
engineers and it was looked at by the
des that said yes you have put in an
adequate amount of money to cover this
for 30 years
so we provided financial insurance in a
manner that was not questioned by des up
until 2016.
so from 2006 when we purchased it we did
the financial assurance up until 2016.
in 2014
the des changed that regulation so if
you go back and you look i think it was
july 14
the regulation changed again we call it
a change you're going to see that the
des in their written comments indicated
that it was a misunderstanding
it was a change such that they said no
longer is it for a fixed 30-year period
now we require you to have that
financial assurance
pretty much in a perpetuity for 30 years
until we figure out that we can close
that landfill
so through that 15 years based upon the
original documentation that we had and
we have letters from the then
commissioner that said
economic corporation we are releasing
money from the trust fund that we
control to allow you to pay expenses
based upon the original agreement we
allow you to take out this money to
cover the remaining 15 years of the
30-year requirement and again that was
signed by the
depart by the commissioner of des
so when they changed it to a rolling 30
years we had already spent fifteen
thirty
30. so after that legislation was
changed we could no longer provide
financial assurance because the money
that we originally had been
using given by those districts to take
ownership and stewardship of the
landfill
wasn't enough to provide another 30
years and so the des said we are not
going to allow you to take money out of
the remaining fund to pay your expenses
of which we owe 172 thousand dollars to
the folks that have been doing the work
at the landfill for us we are not
allowing you to take that money out of
that because you need 30 years so you've
got to figure out some way to come up
with another 15 years of monies well i
can tell you as an economic corporation
if we would have known that this was a
rolling perpetual 30 years we don't have
a revenue stream right our money doing
particular projects
and maybe getting someone in and maybe
selling it that's how we perpetuate our
mission our mission was never to hold an
ash landfill for life i mean we're all
volunteers my day job is a banker so i'm
president of sugar river bank which we
have i am not i am just learning now how
to run a landfill
literally and i have to say the des has
been very good to work with and we've
been working very closely with them as
well as novus engineering um but i can
tell you that the volunteers around that
table
you know they question if indeed you
know we are going to be held to that
when we don't have the money
you know some of the alternatives are
not great some of the alternatives is we
just can't do it so what you're seeing
in that bill at this point in time we
are asking for an appropriation such to
fill that gap and for the appropriation
to go to
the department of environmental services
and to regenerate it
such that we have enough to cover not
only that 30-year period but hopefully
we have enough to cover expenses because
not only do we have to take that chunk
of money which could be upwards of nine
hundred thousand
we can't touch that so the dea says
thank you very much for having nine
hundred thousand vital money which has
to stay there for thirty years you
cannot touch that that is what has to
stay there in order to cover if you
somehow someway
do not provide whatever it is you need
to do so you got to leave that in there
but guess what you also have to have the
30 or 40 000
for the next 30 years to cover the
expenses of that landfill
so
i
we were on track without question we
have
more than enough money to cover the
remaining 15 years but because of that
change in the regulation in 2014 that
put us in a position that this is
untenable
for us to do the right thing
and i'm open for any questions you may
have and i'll do my best
yes go ahead please
representative griffin
red button
red button sure one
doesn't want to stay down i guess
i'll try the blue button is that working
okay um
first of all could you give us your name
again sure it's mark pitkin p-i-t-k-i-n
thank you my question is
if you don't
why wouldn't
why wouldn't you ask for an exemption
from
des
rather than
a half million dollars or whatever we're
asking for
so that that is a great question and i
know that we have a representative from
des that is following me i believe that
they submitted testimony that indicated
the importance of financial assurance
and why it was necessary for the
health and well-being of those that
sort of surround those areas but i am
certainly not the best person but if we
if we were able to get a waiver of that
we would certainly take it but again
that's a great question that i'm sure
that the representative from des would
be able to answer
representative weiler
thank you madam chair
mr pitkin is this uh
is this asheville lined
um
yes so
there's only and i'm told there's only
two ash landfills in the state and ours
is probably one of the best maintained
and managed in the state since day one
and i think that it's also in the
written testimony that we have
maintained that so the answer is yes
it's it's not only ash but it is lined
follow-up
yes go ahead
is there still some leachate from this
that is
that is detected and processed
so there's still leachate but over the
life of the landfill the amount of
leachate has dropped precipitously so it
used to be
tens of thousands of gallons and now i
believe it's five or six thousand
gallons a year
um
and when the process now of working with
des to potentially do some testing of
the leachate in order to reduce some of
the expenses regarding the requirement
for testing to help us out
are there further questions
thank you very much appreciate your
testimony
i will now call on mike wizzanet
from
oh sorry whimset
uh from des
i i believe we already have
kevin
i think we all have the written
testimony
unless it's
yeah
good morning madam chair i'm sorry i
butchered your name that's quite all
right i apologize wouldn't be the first
time
good morning madam chair and members of
the committee for the record my name is
mike wimsat i serve as director of the
waste management division for the new
hampshire department of environmental
services
we certainly appreciate the opportunity
to be here with you this morning to talk
about house bill 1300.
um to be clear the department is not
taking a position on this bill and
that's articulated in the letter that's
being distributed and again i understand
that the letter is also provided
electronically in advance so i think
everyone should have a copy
we're not taking a position on the bill
but we prepared this written testimony
really just to provide some context and
also just to give us an opportunity to
be here to answer any questions that you
might have
um and i think the sponsor and mr pitkin
has described what the what the bill is
seeking here so i won't review that um
but i would like to take a moment just
to explain the importance of landfills
providing financial assurance
for post-closure care
right now in new hampshire there are
approximately 400 closed
uh unlined landfills in the state um and
some closed line landfills has been
discussed here
and they all uh have uh
long-term care requirements associated
with them even after you close the
landfill and what you do to close the
landfills is essentially put a cap over
it make sure that cap is maintained that
the grass cover is mowed that any if
there's leachate collection that you're
collecting and treating the leachate
properly you're managing the gas that
might be generated from the landfill and
then ground and
most importantly in with almost every
facility
monitoring the groundwater around that
to make sure that it's not
creating a situation where it imperils
the quality of nearby drinking water
wells
and
so some of those hazards include the
possibility of impacting groundwater
also landfills can create explosive
gases which can migrate through the soil
and create explosive gas conditions in
nearby buildings so there's a lot of
important work that goes on for
monitoring these landfills in most cases
these landfills are owned by
municipality excuse me municipalities
that uh that pay for the ongoing care of
the of the of the landfills
in the case of a municipality they are
in a position to provide financial
assurance through a mechanism known as a
financial uh local government test so
basically if you municip
there is a requirement that any landfill
operator no matter who they are provide
financial assurance to show
that they have adequate resources to do
the long-term care of the facility and
it's important to understand that that
financial assurance is not necessarily a
fund to be accessed it's to show that in
the case that the the owner of the
landfill becomes insolvent
des would likely be asked to take over
the care of that landfill there's
adequate funds there to make sure that
that's cared for for at least
a 30-year period
that's what the law requires that's what
a operator of landfill is required to do
to be in compliance with the financial
assurance requirements
in the case of most municipalities who
own these facilities they're able to
demonstrate that financial assurance
through what's called the local
government test because in essence
they're they're a taxing authority if
they need you know if they they don't
essentially become insolvent they can
always raise funds if they need to to to
to
meet their meet their responsibilities
but in the case of a private owner of a
landfill or in this case a non-profit
that local government test isn't
available to them because they're not in
the they're not the same thing as a
municipality they're not a taxing
authority so there are a variety of
other mechanisms that they can use
those include surety bonds or in this
case a trust fund which was established
for the to provide the financial
assurance for this facility and mr
picken has described that the history on
this is is a little muddled there have
been some misunderstandings over time
about just what the responsibilities of
econ would be with respect to providing
for financial assurance for this
facility
but i think it needs to be understood
that in essence financial assurance is
something that
is required on a rolling basis the law
change that we made in 2014 was really
intended to clarify um that that that is
a rolling basis there were a number of
people econ is not the only person or
the only operator
that that had the understanding that
they only needed to require provide
financial assurance for 30 years and
then when 30 years was up they didn't
need to have financial assurance anymore
the unfortunate fact associated with
these landfills is that
while their costs to maintain them and
op and in in their post-closure care
period do generally go down over the
years they never necessarily go away
entirely because the landfill is still
if you think about what a landfill is it
encapsulates the waste and it can
continue to pose a risk to groundwater
or gas management or any you know pick
your particular hazard those hazards can
be continue to be posed long beyond the
30-year
that initial 30 years
following closure of the landfill
so that i just want to sort of set the
stage for you there in terms of
what we do so we manage a financial
assurance compliance program where we
require these facilities all operators
to provide every three years an updated
closure cost estimate of what our post
closer care cost estimate of what
they think they're third for a 30 year
period moving out from that date what do
they estimate are their costs for
maintenance of the facility and then
they're required to put to provide some
kind of financial assurance for that
amount of money
in the case of econ unfortunately we
don't have a current 30-year
post-closure care estimate we have about
a 15 years so that's one of the first
thing that needs to happen is they need
to do and we've asked them to do this
and i know they're working diligently to
do it they want to develop that post
that 30-year post-closure care cost
estimate so they know how much financial
insurance they need to provide
what we're pretty confident of is that
the current amount in their trust fund
would not cover the post-closure care
costs for a 30-year period so we're
waiting to to see what that uh
estimate will be and then we're working
with them we
chris aslan from the ag's office and i
went and met uh several weeks back a
couple months now back with uh with econ
and their board and we're trying to work
out some kind of a solution so that they
can get the amount of money that they
need to have in their financial
assurance package
and then also
maybe the more challenging thing or at
least as challenging
is ensuring that they have adequate
funding each year to provide for the
very the actual costs of post-closure
care which for them really include the
cost of you know maintenance and mowing
of the cap
monitoring of the groundwater monitoring
wells
periodically and also as mr picken
indicated uh collection and proper
disposal of the um five or six thousand
gallons of leachate that the that is
collected from the facility each year
and with that i'll i'll leave it at that
and if there are any questions i'm happy
to entertain them
yes please go ahead
yeah mike um thank you for thank you for
uh thank you madam chair and thank you
for agreeing to the question the
question i have is is what's not clear
to me who missed what when where that
allowed this circumstance to be
presented it seems
concerning and just if you can
articulate
clarity for me if you would please sure
thank you representative that's a fair
question and i think you know the the
story here is not is not entirely clear
we um are certainly aware that uh you
know back when the facility was closed
the econ was identified as a it was an
unusual situation
the claremont ash landfill was a
consortium
was used by a consortium of 27 different
towns
most of new hampshire some in vermont as
well
and there really wasn't a clear
pathway for for who you know and the
project sort of owned and operated the
landfill but then it dissolved when when
when when they closed the landfill and
so it really wasn't clear what entity
would would take that and i think mr
pitkin has done a better job than i can
in describing how
econ was identified to to take that on i
i take
we take them at their word we we believe
they did not fully understand what their
responsibilities and requirements were
at the time that they did that i think
that in the communications that have
occurred since then
there have been some miscommunications
from the department i think that we need
to acknowledge in terms that may have
led them to continue to believe that
they only needed to provide
that this this
25 or 30 year period that was then
converging um
but in more recent years we've had very
clear communications to them to indicate
that they do need to have a rolling
30-year period of post-closure care an
estimate of the cost for that and
maintain the
the
financial assurance for that i think um
previously when they were allowed to
access that fund
there was a concern on the i think
because we really wanted to see the care
of the facility continue when they were
saying we need cash to do that annual
care
so we did provide them and i believe in
a couple of instances permission to
access the fund
but then it was really
very clear that the fund did not have
adequate
financial assurance for the 30-year
period and so those subsequent requests
were denied and they've been denied for
about the last five or six years and
that's of course been a source of
frustration for econ because as mr
picken indicated they don't ever they
don't have a revenue source to to
conduct this this work and so
it's really created a bit of a crisis
for them which we're sympathetic to
um the concern for the department is
that
um
you know
all facilities including this one will
continue to have post-closure care costs
associated with them and they need to be
provided for not only in the financial
assurance mechanism but on an ongoing
basis each year those costs need to be
provided
yes you may thank you madam chairman
just for my own notification it seems to
me that there was a well 27 communities
that were in a cooperative so to speak
for this landfill
similar to what we have up north i think
in some cases and and all the
communities chip in together and pay for
and subsidize the cost of that uh
recycling in landfill
so
why was the
i just don't it's not clear to me why
that
wasn't done enough it wasn't done why it
can't happen now because there is there
is um
responsibility by the users of it to
maintain it and that's clear
to me anyways and so why are we here
asking for a half a million dollars for
something that should have happened by
communities
some time ago is by
where i don't know if that's a fair
question or not i think it's a fair
question i'll be honest i i don't know
the answer to in the early going i i
really don't know the history in terms
of what what the discussions were that
led them to say you know as opposed
instead of identifying econ as the owner
of the facility you know having those 27
communities continue to participate as
as sort of co-owners um i think mr
picken indicated that newport had some
concerns about you know the regardless
of what those 27 communities would or
wouldn't do yes landfills located in
newport so they had obviously a very
specific interest in controlling what
happened and that may have led to the to
the agreement and the arrangement that
they entered into as far as
whether it could happen now
um you know
it's a legal question i probably would
try not to to go too far down the pike
on because i'm not qualified for that
but i think that you know the
there's been some discussion i think in
the last board meeting that that he kind
of had about that and i'm not sure they
have an appetite for that right now or
and i think they're probably trying to
assess how how successful they'd be in
trying to go down that road
uh mr pinken i understand you had an
answer
on that if you would uh come up and use
one of the microphones
[Music]
so i have the distinct pleasure or maybe
not but i was actually on the
committee at that point in time
so with regards to the purchase of the
landfill there were a couple
indemnifications that were approved as
part of that process so the first
indemnification was of the 27
communities that said if you have a
major spill if you have a circular event
we know we are responsible
but also as part of that deal they said
we are putting in at that point in time
1.1 million we have put in the monies
that you have estimated and your experts
have estimated and the des has looked at
and blessed for financial assurance 1.1
million and we are also giving you 200
for you to use should you have any type
of spill
to use
in order to figure out what is the spill
what needs to be done what is the cost
and then if it is a circular event you
come to us
but as part of that
at least the 27 town said but we need an
indemnity agreement that you're not
going to come to us every single year
when your costs change so there is a
legal indemnity agreement that basically
says econ cannot go back to them
unless it is based on the indemnity of
the major spill because they put in 1.1
million plus 200 000. so again if it was
only 30 years that would have covered
everything because we have 15 years left
so the issue is now is
the reason that we don't have enough
money to cover it is not because the
original amount was not put in it's no
longer 30 years now it's 30 years every
year so to go back to them they're going
to say well same reason we're here
that's not what we thought and we've got
an indemnification agreement that you
can't come back to us if there is a
change
so that is basically why it is difficult
and we are working with an environmental
attorney attorney cheney um who's very
familiar with these and again based upon
that subordinate or um indemnification
agreement unless it's a major spill you
know that was the agreement
thank you thank you very much are there
further questions yes uh
representative lynn i wonder if i could
ask you has can you tell us
from your knowledge as this
has something like this happened before
in other words where the state has been
asked to
to kind of come in and provide funding
uh for this kind of thing i i guess what
i'm really what i'm really concerned
about is what kind of a precedent this
would set and you know maybe maybe it's
not setting a president because it's
been done before
i am not aware of any other landfill
operator that has come in and asked
asked a legislator to sponsor a bill to
provide funding for their financial
assurance
representative
you were too close
my question
is what happens if they say enough
we're done
i don't want to do this anymore
i'm not going to try to raise funds i've
i've had it
what happens i mean what what what
recourse does does the state have
it's closed
right well i certainly want to speculate
on enforcement i learned a long time ago
not to do that i mean the state has
authority to and the department is
granted with authority by the
legislature to enforce rsa 149 m which
is a solid waste statute so we would
have whatever enforcement authorities
are available to us under that statute
for in the abstract for any party who
doesn't meet its financial assurance
requirements um and that's you know
starts out administratively with you
know obviously sending letters and
saying you need to you're not in
compliance with your requirements you
need to meet them and then of course
whatever other civil or you know um
authorities that it has under the
statute and
in this particular case if the facility
um you know if econ said we're just
checking out we're not going to do this
anymore then
under the current circumstances um i
believe the the balance that is in the
trust fund right now would would come to
the state
to use for
the post-closure care of the facility
eventually that would be exhausted
presumably there would still be
post-closure care to be to be
conducted each year and the cost of that
barring anyone else being able to do it
would would potentially come to the
state to oversee to hire contractors to
perform that post-closure care and the
taxpayers would have to pay for that
through you know the budget process
you have a follow-up yeah
because what what what i'm hearing is we
have an insolvent business
and
the state's being asked to make it quote
solvent
uh in order to have this fund
requirement
it confuses me
and i guess that
representative flynn has the same
question it confuses me why is the state
involved in this
i know why you're involved in it but why
is the state a funding agent
for an entity
uh that's a private entity
and the the agency is not taking a
position on this bill and i don't have
an answer for that
i guess i i'm confused about why they
have to keep operating
if once they're insolvent and they hold
up their hand say take the money
they have that option i would assume
um
i guess any operator or landfill has the
option of
potentially abdicating its
responsibilities um
however
um
again i i don't want to speculate on
what you know how the agency would
respond to that or its enforcement
authorities i don't think that's
appropriate for me to do that
our job in administering the statute is
to ensure that all landfill operators
have adequate financial assurance and
that they conduct their post-closure
care on an annual basis
um and in all cases they're they're
generally doing that um
and in fact it has to be said the econ
um in
partnership with the town of newport has
been doing that they've been performing
their post-closure care this this is not
a facility that is not being cared for
so i'm happy to report that
um and there is some money although
probably
certainly not an adequate amount of
money in the trust fund to provide the
financial assurance it just needs to be
increased but even if you if you could
magically make that financial assurance
adequate
um in in in that trust fund
there's still the issue of which we're
very sympathetic to of having that
adequate funding each year to perform
the post-closure care
uh thank you
are there any further questions uh yes
representative edwards
thank thank you madam chair i
i think i have four but the the key one
to me is
um
given that we're talking about a 30-year
period and making sure we can reach the
end of a rolling 30-year period i'm just
curious what the emergency is i mean
we're bringing this item in in
mid-budget cycle and if there's not a
funding emergency because there's enough
money for five or ten years
uh why why are we not dealing with this
in a regular budget cycle
well to that part of your question i
would just say i i don't have an answer
for that this is not a bill that edes
has sponsored or you know has asked to
ask to come forward um i would note
however that
and that's part of the importance of the
conversation the financial assurance is
not intended to be used each year to
perform the annual care it's intended to
be there as
a trust fund in the event that the
operator
doesn't continue meeting their
responsibilities for post-closure care
so
what should happen here is that
financial assurance needs to be brought
up to the amount required and then
the operator in this case econ needs to
have adequate funding each year which is
not a lot of money but it's it's you
know it's meaningful um to do that
post-closure care outside without
accessing the funds in the trust fund
they should not be looking to access the
trust fund funds
follow-up
thank you for that that that's more
clear to me it sounds like we're setting
up more of a bond than an operating fund
is that a yes or an uh
yeah
i think that's a reasonable analogy
okay and then on page two of uh the
department's testimony it refers to
like all other active and closed
landfills in the state this sort of gets
to representative lin and emmerich's uh
question
do we
are there any other landfills or any
other projects similar to this that we
need to be worried about
off the top my head i'm not aware
specifically of any facilities that
don't have adequate financial assurance
right now they're well i
i don't want to talk we don't know all
the facts but there may be one in
central new hampshire that
the ownership scenario is is muddled and
so it's
there there may be one more that where
we've got some concerns about financial
assurance okay uh you have a follow-up
uh
last one thank you for your patience
madam chair um
okay so i listened to the president last
night talk about uh federal funding for
uh replacing lead pipes so that we have
safe drinking water and since we're
talking about leaching of
landfills
are you aware of whether or not there's
any federal funds
that would be accessible for
this sort of endeavor
i'm not currently aware of any funds in
that category but i have to say the the
the
guidance provided by the federal
government for
use of the funds from the american
rescue plan act and the bipartisan
infrastructure law is still evolving and
we we're certainly keeping a close eye
on that to understand what the range of
options might be for use of those funds
and we'd certainly look you know
anything look like it could be access
for something like this we would
certainly bring it to econ's attention
i i just have one question that is
confusing me a little bit
and that is you say
that you have to keep a 30-year
fund there just in case so if i'm
closing a landfill i have to provide
assurances that i have 60 years worth of
money
to take at least 60 years or is it 90 or
120 no it it's it's it's a rolling 30 so
i mean so let's say on in year one you
close the landfill right you need to
show that you have adequate funding
let's say in the example if you're using
a for trust fund that you have a trust
fund has enough money that if you walked
away today the state could take over the
management of the facility and have
enough money in that trust fund to to
provide post-closure care for 30 years
assuming you don't walk away though the
expectation is you maintain that
financial assurance
and you also do spend whatever
incremental amounts of money from other
funds that are needed to do that
post-closure care each year so what
you're saying excuse me what you're
saying is that it's for a 30-year period
period
it's for right and what we call it a
rolling third because what it means is
under the law you have to reassess your
um
your you estimate your closure costs
every three years so let's say year one
you you do what i just described year
four you come in and you say okay here's
our here's what we think our costs are
and you look at the amount in the trust
fund and if the costs have gone down
you're fine because the trust fund will
have enough money to cover that if
they've gone up you might have to add
more money to the trust fund to to uh to
uh cover that that difference but the
idea is that at all times during your
ownership of the facility
you maintain 30 years financially enough
money to cut in the trust fund to cover
the next 30 years of care
and i guess that gets to my question
when does the next 30 years expire
sure so it never expires basically but
what i would say though is that in
practice what we see is that the cl the
care costs in the early years are higher
and they go down over time because as
the landfill matures
um maybe the monitoring gets so stable
you don't need to monitor as often you
might still need to monitor but you
don't have to do it as often or you
don't have to do as many wells
there are some costs that are going to
be kind of standardized like maintaining
and mowing the cap you're going to have
to do that
that doesn't get the grass keeps growing
it doesn't change so oh someone here
today said they were going to stop the
grass from growing
i don't remember who it was there are
ways to do that but
we'll encourage them
are there any further questions
seeing none thank you very much and i
have no additional pink cards
but i do have um
some people that signed in that didn't
speak
and that is senator ruth ward who is in
favor of the bill
i have a
bruce jasper who is also invading bill
and representative judy aaron who is
also in favor of the bill
so with that information i will
close the hearing
i will now open the hearing on
10 1054.
is there anyone here
to speak to 1054
okay
uh just just leave it there
are you representative uh toddy here
okay great
thank you
this will be very short
i know
well set yep i'm all set good morning
madam chair and members of the committee
my name is douglas trottier i'm from
district six belmont
before you i'm presenting house bill
crying an audit on the new hampshire
state police at this point i'm going to
ask that the committee itl this bill
because after doing further research i
learned that there is another process
that i could use and i don't feel that
we need to go forward with this bill
thank you thank you are there any
questions
seeing none i will close the hearing
thank you
very nice
could i ask everyone to stand for three
minutes
and then we will
have
the folks from das
speak to us about the
annual comprehensive financial report
did everybody get a copy of that
i know exactly
am i thinking
but
so many teachers um sick
so let's blow up the whole educational
system
that's crazy
they said that someone's happy
i don't know
i know
well that's that's that's right
the state has the responsibility for
showing there's parameters for how he
didn't make it right
[Music]
is
managing documents
[Music]
this process
because
is
also
let me breathe
is
yes
um
uh
that was uh
petrie's
i think chair going to lose some people
because they're going to be like i don't
know okay
um
i asked
d.a.s to come in and
go
through the cafe with us
because
many of the folks that are
now on finance
have
never had the
never have gone through
the kafra or understand
what information is in there
and so
if if we could
just kind of
give us a
kind of give us a
outline
who does what work
why do we do it
for for those of us that are on the
fiscal committee
we've heard some of this from the
kpmg that actually does the audit
but
i feel that it is essential
that we have an understanding
of what the uh
kafra is all about
so
if we could i'd appreciate it and thank
you
thank you for having us uh i'm charlie
arlinghaus i'm the commissioner of
administrative services and this is dana
call your friendly state comptroller
um
so i'm uh
i'm here to accompany and dana's here
because she's smart um which is a nice
tag team it removes a lot of burden off
of me
um
so i'm gonna start and explain what the
kafir is and why we have a kafir in a
big picture sense and then and then dana
as the state chief accounting officer
will explain to you you know the
technical details um
why you should be happy um with it and
why it worked out really well
um
there are a couple things the state does
and the state has done in new hampshire
since about 1931
when the office of the comptroller was
established as a means of fiscal control
the state does an annual financial
report sometime in the 80s we switched
to doing it by
you know the real way government
generally accepted accounting principles
um
which i think was a bit of a task at the
time um i like to say to people that if
we don't do this you can't exist as a
state we would have to shut down our
business
and the business being state government
that would be problematic in a couple of
ways right
um
although taxpayers might be happy
because i think we would also have to
stop collecting taxes
um the
but if unless you're an anarchist it
would be
it would be problematic um
basically i i think that the caver
serves um
a few different roles and i i came upon
this in a answer to a question at fiscal
um the other day and i thought about it
this way
there's a way in which um this document
is so it's fundamentally it's an
accounting document right it's a whole
bunch of people with green eye shade um
going over stuff and reading through
them and and figuring out if we recorded
everything the right way and are we
tracking everything
but at its most basic level for for the
people of the state and for the
management of the state the the policy
management of the state which is which
is you all um it's a transparency
document this is this is somebody has
looked at the way state government works
somebody has examined what we're doing
someone has examined the money coming in
and going out and you don't have to take
anybody's word for it that money is
coming in and going out you have a whole
bunch of different eyeballs looking at
it and then that document is posted
far and wide for everyone to see people
who buy bonds for the state can look at
it expect to look at it or they won't
loan us money people who for some reason
want to see if we're trying to pull
anything sneaky um can look at it people
who want to see what our long-term
obligations are can look at it and say
is there anything going on that no one's
talking about in the future and from a
financial standpoint the entirety of
state government and the the health of
state government is basically in the
picture you don't you don't look at what
we spent last week on groceries you look
at all the obligations going up and
yeah we have money in the bank account
right now but the mortgage payment
hasn't been paid yet oh geez that's out
there and there's sections in it that
have that talk about lawsuits that might
be coming up so from a transparency and
accountability standpoint it's a very
fundamentally important document
um i i mean i do say that we would have
to shut down as a state without doing it
frankly people would look at us weird
we'd be you know
the best modern example is we'd be
illinois
um and um
sorry to anybody who grew up in chicago
but it would you know i mean we i use
illinois because everybody's sort of
nonpartisan everyone knows it's a basket
case and their governors usually go to
jail and stuff like that um and it's and
everything's a mess there and we're not
a mess and we produce a document every
year that show it's not a mess early in
the history when they established a
comptroller right departments used to
spend what they spent and then three
quarters of the way through the year
they'd come to the legislature and go
hey um we ran out
can we get some more
and the people got sick of that and they
wanted you know budgets and control and
all that so early on the executive
branch did its own audit
fairly early they separated that it's
part of the creation of uh
an office that became the legislative
budget assistant was that a dif one
branch
audits the other branch
um
uh big picture we have all the numbers
in there the numbers are for the
entirety state government but the
legislative branch audits the um
executive branch and they do so
not by
you know these two people
um running around to every department of
state government but they do it by
hiring an auditing firm lately that
auditing firm is very nationally
recognized kpmg
um i don't know what kpmg stands for
anymore i think one of them is pete
marwick but i don't even know
but
there you go and um so that's the
fundamental what it is and you know um
basically if you've got a question about
whether the numbers are right
about anything going on in state
government you can turn to this and look
at it and the truth is that 99 of us
um will have trouble without a guide
right because it's a complicated
accounting document but one of the
things like everything that's related to
transparency and accountability
the fact that it's there and somebody
somebody with a little more experience
can look at it and raise questions is is
the thing that
keeps us all honest so to speak that's
that's a way too high profile an
overview and dana will talk about things
you should care about
[Music]
okay all right thank you charlie good
afternoon
um i'm gonna remove this so i just don't
sound muffled
the um
the effort is
compiled in the office of the
comptroller but it takes
obviously a whole slew of folks around
agencies to compile this document we
have six months to issue it so the state
fiscal year is june 30 and statutorily
by 12 31 we need to issue the document
what it does is it combines all of all
of our entities into one place so you'll
notice if you flip through it
you're going to see other entities such
as the new hampshire retirement system
the university system
there's a community college system
there's a variety of other entities plus
our own the liquor commission the
lottery commission and turnpike
turnpike they all have their own
separate audits so they all either have
an outside firm or lba
and they hire someone to do their own
separate audits and they actually many
of them have their own separate document
similar to this
so what we do is while that's going on
and they're getting audited uh kpmg is
auditing the entirety and we put it all
together in one document so you get a
bigger picture of everything combined in
one
but you can also go to those other
audits if you needed more information on
those separate entities so it's helpful
from that sense but every entity
again who needs one mainly for bonding
or anything else is going to have a
similar document and they're put
together under similar accounting
standards and they're the layout is very
similar so even you know even private
companies would have an annual report
and it would look somewhat similar
we work under government accounting
standards so we have some different
things but um essentially it starts with
the um there's a transmittal letter
which is written by us and
opens up the document and talks about a
lot of the things that you would all be
interested in i think when i was here
previously i pointed you to page eight
which is where the surplus statement is
for the general education trust fund uh
because that is generally what
when you're looking at budgets that's
what you're most interested in
so i can just give you a quick walk
through if you like um
after the transmittal we have the audit
opinion which is important obviously and
that's what kpmg presented to fiscal
there is some analysis as well but if
you turn to page
i'm sorry 28 and 29
that's essentially our balance sheet for
the state
so that is
with everything combined all the
entities i mentioned
that is where we stand from a balance
sheet perspective
it includes all of our capital assets as
well as our long-term liabilities such
as pension obligations and
the like outstanding debt
and so that's a that's a big picture and
then if you turn to
page 33 is the balance sheet of the
funds you're probably most familiar with
which is general fund highway fund
education fund and you can take a look
at what those balances look like and
their fund balances
and i would mention the
statements are obviously on a
gaap basis we refer to which is accrual
accounting
generally accepted accounting principles
so it's not necessarily on a budgetary
basis but if you look through the
document elsewhere in the document we do
provide some budgetary information to
kind of give you a sense
of budget to actuals
so be beyond the statement there's a
there's multiple pages of footnotes and
what we do there is we take a particular
line item that might be of interest and
provide
extra pages of charts and information to
break down the details so if for
instance you were interested in capital
assets you would go to that page and
look at the details if you're interested
in debt or how long our debt excuse me
how long are debt payments go out you
would look at that page
so that's that's basically the financial
statements and the footnotes portion um
and again there's a lot of schedules in
the back that break down the other
entities that we talked about
as well like this state revolving fund
is one of those and there's a breakdown
of that and more towards the middle
and then the back section is a lot of um
informational um so there's there's a
lot of we call the statistical section
where you might find information on
number of employees on a variety of
information statewide that we compile
and that information is not necessarily
audited but most of it aligns with the
financial information so if you wanted
to look at
more details on the
general fund surplus you'd find a page
there that would align with how we
presented in the front
so again
we obviously this is a lengthy effort
for us and and it takes um it takes the
variety of agencies that provide us
information that goes into this document
so it really is a statewide effort
to to complete this and obviously our
goal is to complete it on time and
have a clean audit opinion as a result
which we did again this year so
um
i think that's the that's the highlights
but i'll be happy to take questions
okay uh representative weiler
thank you madam chair thank you madam
controller i've had a constituent that's
had a lot of questions lately about the
retirement system
and i found the section in here very
incomplete i did notice that gasby
or 75 said we had to start listing opeb
liabilities which
put us
a couple of billion dollars in the hole
as our financial position but what i do
recall
is back in 2011 when we decided that we
were in the hole on the overall
actuarial retirement system that we
needed to change it
so changes were made
and
at the time i think we were two billion
short in that retirement system and we
were hoping that we would make gains on
that in a 30-year projection
however
nothing is showing in here to show
whether we've made progress on that gap
which i believe is now twice what it was
in 2011 but there's nothing in here that
gives you any information and when i
recently
a year ago said we needed to
audit
the retirement system because you're
only making one percent return
they suddenly this year say they're
making a 26 return but that isn't in
here either so
i think we ought to go and kick them in
the butt over retirement system and say
you're giving us just
nothing
right you put in a 6.75
assumed return and you never give the
real return ever in these things
and it and it wouldn't be in this
document so i don't have a great answer
for that because the retirement system
does have their own separate audit and
they have separate actuarial reports so
but we can look into providing more in
in the
the financial obligation section is just
the state employee portion of the nhrs
obligation
so they have an entire system that they
provide financial statements for but we
do have ability in our narrative at the
front where we could talk more about the
impact of the retirement system to our
employees so that is an area we can look
to add language
well it's also a big effect on our
overall standing which isn't reflected
in here it talks about the opeb
liability putting us
our standard position two billion
dollars in the hole from where we were
kind of neutral but i think we're
actually six billion dollars in the
whole if all things should be reported
the
something one important thing to think
about
excuse me um
the state
this is a this is a picture of state
government and it's the state
government's financial position etc um
the
the you know in some states where the
retirement system is part of state
government in some place states where
it's not
ours has not since a court case from
20 or 30 years ago at this point um and
so they do have they do have their own
financials a lot of the things you're
asking about the the
uh the annualized rate of return etc are
in their financial documents and they
put them out
the only thing i would add is is
we
we're in a situation with them where you
know we can call them up and ask them
questions and the typical response is
you're not the boss of us
and um and we're not we're not the boss
of them and so our relationship with
them is is often very good
and often
you're not the boss of us and so so a
lot of the information you want you're
going to you really are going to have to
get from them our goal is to is to make
sure that we we quantify on an annual
basis the state's liability as and
as to the rate of return
um you should call gerard
my my predecessor
gerard hired me so you you know you got
to be thankful
um i
i will i will mention though uh on one
of the pages i pointed out to you on our
balance sheet we do distinguish between
our opeb liability which is our other
post-employment benefits
and the pension liability so we have two
liabilities on the books um one is about
a billion dollars one is about two
billion dollars so it's it's there but
it's just our peace
thank you uh representative emrick
my question is
is there a section in here that it
says
at the end at the as of june 30th before
the accrual setups and everything
there was a surplus over budget
many millions of dollars
is there a section here that says what
happened to that or does he just kind of
do this
if you look at page eight
so historically it's it's sort of an uh
inside joke that um
occasionally people will call up and say
how's the kaffir look and they don't
actually care
and they want to look at page eight
and it's what they want to see is the
surplus statement and surplus statement
is a is a thing as you i'm sure a lot of
you know lba does a surplus statement
all the time
and i think during your budget process
we'll typically do
you know updates four five six times um
and probably at some point um around
this time of the year this is the actual
audited version so so it resembles very
closely that statement but it will show
you for example how much there was um
how much there was at the end of the
year what expenditures actually turned
out to be how much lapses actually were
fiscal year 20 20 21 et cetera
what happened to the surplus was any of
it transferred here there or elsewhere
many years not this past year their
transfers made to the education trust
fund to shore up the the
nominal deficit in that which i which is
its own sort of fiction
and where it happens and here it'll show
a very large balance
because what's supposed to happen at the
end of the second year of a biennium is
that everything in savings goes to the
rainy day fund and you will notice the
rainy day fund account
uh is 257.8 million which i'm pretty
sure is
pretty close to double as high as it's
ever been
i mean it's a remarkable number
so it's all right there so that's it's
all there
that's how you that's how you can check
is look at page 8.
excuse me
i would also
like to commend the
das and in particular comptroller for
the information that is included in here
if
if you don't know an answer to something
about finances
if you go to the section in here that
talks about it
the answer is here
and
too
too often
uh you know we joke about the fact that
this is great bedtime reading because
you'll be asleep before you open it
but
every
every once in a while
it's good to just open up a page and
read what it has to say
you know it's like obviously ken was
concerned
ken was concerned about
the retirement system
you know he went to that section in here
and found some problems
and it doesn't matter you know what it
is
but i will also say
that
um besides the kafra
we get all kinds of
comprehensive financial reports
coming up
tomorrow at fiscal
we have
liquor
turnpike
and something else
lottery
thank you
and uh was there three there were three
okay
and um
so they will be giving fiscal
a little bit more in-depth
report
about their
current status financial status
than what the kafra provided
so and i think if i'm not mistaken
i receive the unh
financial report
i don't know if i've gotten the
community college one yet or not i'm if
you know
who knows
but they're all supposed to be they're
all supposed to be done by 31 december
so it's not so i'm sure it's out there
but for the committee if you are
interested in any of these audits
they are absolutely available down in
the lba
and um
to me these are a lot more exciting
reading
than
the normal audit reports that we get
so
anyhow i'm just i'm just telling you
from my perspective but
this is kind of
for
the financial people this is kind of
their bible
for 2021
and we get one of these every year
and um
we had not like i said we had not had a
presentation because
last year
i don't even think we did it over zoom
um last year because of coven and all
that kind of stuff we didn't really have
a
didn't really have a presentation or
the opportunity to pass this out so
i thank you very much are there any
other questions and and listen if you
have questions
you can always call
either the lba
or the comptroller's office
and i know that they will have
answers because
obviously the writer
and the writer and the reviewer
always
always manages
so i believe that thank you very much
thank you for the opportunity okay i
believe our next
meeting
is on wednesday
with division one and division two
of three
will um
set up a time
for
division two
uh which will obviously not be next week
because we don't have the time it'll be
the following week
and um
if anyone wants to come to fiscal
tomorrow
you're more than welcome to
see us spend multi-million dollars
most of it in arpa money and so
that option that option is always there
and other than that
thank you all for coming and have a
great day
it is
uh
i've got a 1 30 meeting
i'll bring you the receipt